Truly great film trilogies are few and far
between.
Sure, there are standouts like Star Wars and
Lord of the Rings.
But besides those, an unblemished trilogy
is a shockingly rare thing.
Plenty of franchises go straight downhill
after the opening chapter.
What's even worse, though, is a trilogy that's
held back from perfection by a single entry.
It's maddening for fans of the story being
told, and more often than not, it denies fans
the story structure or resolution they desire.
With all that in mind, here's a look at some
memorable trilogies ruined by one movie.
Spider-Man
It's hard to overstate the massive success
of Sam Raimi's first two Spider-Man films.
They were crucial in creating the modern superhero
boom as we know it.
Spider-Man and Spider-Man 2 showed modern
audiences that the genre could still work
in the wake of '90s bombs like Batman & Robin.
Watching them today, it's easy to understand
why.
They're clear labors of love, and with the
second chapter ending on a cliffhanger for
the ages, it seemed that the third installment
was primed for a killer finale.
Unfortunately, Raimi butted heads with the
studio during production of Spider-Man 3.
He was ultimately forced to include popular
comics villain Venom, making for a bloated
and convoluted story that lacks the heart
of the previous two installments.
There's simply too much going on, and the
campier moments are tonally jarring against
the more serious elements.
While a fourth installment was considered
and planned, Sony ultimately decided to abandon
Raimi's Spidey for a rebooted model under
new director Marc Webb.
Blade
They may not get the respect that the X-Men
and Spidey movies do, but the first two Blade
films are just as integral to the modern superhero
movie era.
While directors Stephen Norrington and Guillermo
del Toro deserve a great deal of credit for
making the films work as well as they do,
the success really comes down to Wesley Snipes.
He embodies the calm, collected cool of the
character with a performance that feels effortless.
But it all went wrong in the third installment,
Blade: Trinity.
Set drama and a studio feud with Snipes saw
writer David S. Goyer step in as a last-minute
replacement director.
The result is a deeply disappointing conclusion
to a trilogy, and a character, that deserves
better.
"You gotta be kidding me"
Aside from a quickly canceled TV show, we
haven't seen Blade onscreen since.
Iron Man
There are few superhero origin films as perfect
as 2008's Iron Man.
It's the film that gave us Robert Downey Jr.'s
Tony Stark, one of the all-time great pieces
of movie casting.
As Stark, Downey could read the phonebook
and make it fun.
Still, Iron Man 2 is something of a mess,
and the only thing stopping the Iron Man trilogy
from being one of the best of all time.
It's a film clearly burdened by expectations
and responsibility.
It has to introduce Black Widow to the MCU
and expand other side characters.
On top of that is an ambitious but utterly
nonsensical plot involving the invention of
a new element.
"This is the key to the future.
I'm limited by the technology of my time.
But one day you'll figure this out."
Iron Man 2 didn't tank the MCU by any means,
but it's early evidence that these films are
far from infallible.
X-Men
It's pretty standard for blockbuster films
to announce their release date years in advance
these days, long before a creative team has
been assembled.
It's crucial to remember, though, that that
wasn't always the case.
After the first two films in the X-Men franchise
were met with critical acclaim and great financial
success, the trilogy's conclusion, The Last
Stand, was slated for release before the script
had been finalized.
This turned out to be its downfall.
After Brian Singer and Matthew Vaughn both
dropped out of directing, Fox finally settled
on Brett Ratner, who at that point barely
had a year to make the film.
Multiple cast members now had scheduling conflicts
as well, leading to some strange character
rewrites to account for their absences.
That the film came out at all is a small miracle
and certainly commendable in a certain light.
However, the end product is still pretty lousy.
"Don't let it control you."
It was such a disaster that it effectively
tanked this cinematic incarnation of the X-Men
until they reappeared for a brief swan song
in 2014's Days of Future Past.
Men in Black
Will Smith will always be a huge star, but
he was a special kind of huge star in the
'90s.
Any project he led was more or less guaranteed
to succeed.
Among the biggest of his hits is 1997's stylish
sci-fi action comedy Men in Black.
He starred as loudmouthed Agent J, a brilliant
foil to his straight and narrow partner, Agent
K, played to perfection by Tommy Lee Jones.
Fifteen years later, Men in Black III arrived,
wrapping up the story of Agents J and K perfectly,
due in no small part to a killer performance
by Josh Brolin as a younger K.
"We'll take it from here"
"K?
K?!
K!
AAHH!"
Why did it take 15 years for this hit trilogy
to conclude?
One answer, unfortunately, is that the second
film is downright lousy.
Men in Black II feels like a recycled version
of its predecessor with none of the charm
or surprise.
It may have been a box office hit, but it
didn't exactly leave audiences hungry for
more.
"Tell me something we don't know."
"Ya, tell me something we don't know.
I'm so sorry."
"God bless you."
"Thank you."
There's no telling the heights the franchise
could have reached had the second film not
dropped the ball so hard.
Thor
The first installment in the Thor trilogy
may not be the best the MCU has to offer,
but it's a solid origin story with Shakespearean
flair thanks to director Kenneth Branagh.
It almost feels quaint: a quiet little character
study about an arrogant boy who wants to be
king but isn't ready.
Thor: Ragnarok, on the other hand, is a nutty
cosmic romp full of laughs and unparalleled
art direction and visual design.
Thor: The Dark World is the black sheep of
the trilogy, not so much bad as it is dull.
It fails to build on the sense of wonder instilled
in the first film.
It feels bland and by the numbers, and it
often looks like someone scribbled over the
first film's bright color palette with a grey
crayon.
Frankly, it may be the worst movie in the
MCU.
"What the hell was that?!
And why are you smiling?"
"There's nothing more reassuring than realizing
that the world is crazier than you are."
The Dark World exhausts the old version of
what a Thor movie should be, to the point
that Ragnarok had no choice but to try something
new.
Ultimately it's a good thing that Ragnarok
was able to happen, even if it meant enduring
a pretty bland Thor movie first.
Still, it's hard not to wish the Thor trilogy
had maintained more consistency.
The Ocean Trilogy
When the right performers, script, and director
align, a movie can feel effortlessly fun.
Steven Soderbergh's Vegas heist film Ocean's
11 is one of those movies.
Featuring a killer cast that includes George
Clooney, Brad Pitt, Matt Damon, Julia Roberts,
and Andy Garcia, Ocean's 11 is so entertaining
that it's almost impossible to turn away from.
Its second sequel, Ocean's 13, is similarly
rewatchable, aided greatly by the inclusion
of Al Pacino as the villain.
Ocean's 12, however, very nearly spoils the
stew.
You can't help but get the feeling when watching
it that Soderbergh and company wanted an excuse
to hang out in Europe and went on to tailor
the film to suit their vacation needs.
Everyone seems to be having a good time, but
the spark present in the first and third films
is gone.
Throw in a genuinely bizarre subplot involving
Julia Roberts' character masquerading as Julia
Roberts, and you've got a shockingly lousy
film as the direct follow-up to one of the
most entertaining movies of the century.
The Matrix
The Matrix changed the game upon its release
in 1999.
Even today, it feels like a revelation.
It pushes genre boundaries, melding high-minded
science fiction with breathtaking action shot
in the innovative "bullet time" style.
It gives us a cast of memorable characters
and injects themes of existentialism and Buddhism
into what could have been a cut-and-dry sci-fi
adventure.
Its first sequel, The Matrix Reloaded, doesn't
quite reach the heights of its predecessor,
but then again, what could?
It's still a fun, interesting action romp
that expands on the themes introduced in the
first film.
It all comes crashing down with The Matrix
Revolutions, a bloated mess that's too long
and devoid of anything meaningful or important.
The transgressive themes of the franchise
are cast aside for more special effects, eventually
oversaturating the film, and very nearly the
trilogy as a whole.
It fails to deliver a satisfying ending to
a story its predecessors got audiences deeply
invested in, and the fact that Neo's journey
never got the resolution it deserved is one
of the true missed opportunities in recent
film history.
"Is it over?"